two fat ones for more than a hundred
years Chadwicks has been selling black
pudding to the people of berry they know
a thing or two about budgeting here but
yesterday's Cuts have got Tony worried
yeah for the gas
help with the electric those are the
sort of things that every day Joel like
myself appreciate it the only thing is
he's gambled so much
235 billion pounds if it works I shake
his hand
but if it isn't I'll be in the queue at
the IMF with him do you think it will
work
to be honest I don't think so
this Market's been running for more than
570 years Traders young and old set up
business including Chelsea he runs a
nail salon she's hoping to buy her first
home and while cuts to stamp Duty will
help owning still seems Out Of Reach
trying to get a deposit together and
nowadays is like ridiculous as well as
living and the electric price is going
up as well it's like you're constantly
watching your smart meters what you're
turning on and what you can turn off as
well so yeah it's really tricky
the chancellor insists these tax cuts
are fair but in places like Berry it's a
high risk strategy yes this mini budget
is a big economic gamble but it's also a
political one this red wolf seat only
has a Tory majority of 105 votes and if
these tax cuts don't trickle down here
then many believe it could switch back
to labor
just doesn't feel like it's going to
help anyone and other than the Richer
people it's a very narrow margin the
conservative win so I don't think
they'll be able to hold the seat going
forward it'll go back to labor it is a
political gamble it doesn't matter how
much they throw at it I think
everybody's had enough of the
conservative party they need to try
something else do you think that if this
doesn't work for the people of berry
that it could backfire there's a good
chance yeah I mean I think it's a 50 50
chance I think that it will backfire you
know
this whole plan is about growth if it's
to work the benefits must be felt here
in the market just as much as in the
city down white is Sky News in Berry